[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans six ans
par les sports c'est le deuxième numéro
de cette saison sur tv à 78 au programme
comme toujours une dose de bonne humeur
des analyses sportives et surtout des
coups de gueule et des à débat nos
chroniqueurs sont avec nous sur ce
plateau présentation en musique on
commence un à droite c'est un pistard
passionnés de roller de voile et du jeu
pokémon gosset notre consultant cyclisme
on le surnomme le capitaine notre
chroniqueur getjar y est avec notre
tourneur on s'installe quand allez-vous
super c'est très bien en grande forme
vous avez des
bruits oui c'est pour ça alors voile
c'est récent
principalement
le vrai le vélo en priorité et popiel
d'autant que des choses plus est
d'autant plus que ben voila je suis dans
la philippe rossini pour une deuxième
deuxième saison avec le bo de champion
du monde on peut quand même être fiers
et faire un beau cocorico on vous voit
avec un grand sourire aujourd'hui fier
ont continué notre tour de table musique
il fait partie du gratin des
chroniqueurs c'est un grand
professionnel il connaît tout sur tout
certains le surnomment à l'encyclopédie
moi je préfère le surnom d' italiana
lover grégory cas là les journalistes
chic
bon genre michael bonjour yann bonjour à
tous comment allez vous m'écoutez très
bien on a repris la saison en club
amateur soupa sanitaire mais au moins on
peut jouer dans ces conditions espérer
une saison complète pour cette année si
on a l'habitude de vous voir avec vos
petites lunettes avec le drapeau italien
blanc aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs je
plussoie sur le titre d' allah philippe
et moi je rajoute que chez les filles et
bien c'est bolzano in italienne qui a
remporté le titre de championne du monde
donc l'année parfaite italienne continue
décidément ces italiens cette année
c'est une belle année c'est une belle
année on continue à ma droite musique il
est de retour dans cette émission il est
à basketteur il a une grande carrière il
a toujours une grande carrière puisqu'il
est notamment passé par fatigué
aujourd'hui à l'entente le chesnay
versailles où il claque des cars un
point par match on le surnomme lebron
james des yvelines bomba cei et avec les
autres grands syndicats
quand allez-vous bamba savariau très
content de vous recevoir dans cette
émission par m donc c'est votre deuxième
troisième apparition
en forme une grande joie quand points
par match c'est pas mal on va essayer
cette année
on a gardé le meilleur pour la fin
musique c'est notre dessert dans ceux ci
ont parlé sport à chaque émission il
fait toujours la différence est un
ailier des bords d'un basketteur
qu'hilton qui sublime frappe en pleine
lucarne genlis ex-coach de plaisir et
avec une motion rigal bonsoir à tous
quand sarah coach impeccable un super
bon trois quarts aile dunker
donc tu veux bacs avec un prix pauline
mais par contre d'un sport moi j'suis
pas de spécialité vous commun comme
organe vous connaissez tous surtout
ball rugby mais sinon
on verra ça dans cette émission hameau
de boxe pour commencer un taudis et yoka
29 ans a de plus en plus d'ambition il a
battu récemment un roland garros le
croate pétards milhazes dans un beau
combat une victoire qui a galvanisé les
villageois originaires de chanteloup les
vignes et qu'il y va surtout donner
confiance ce week-end il a déclaré après
la victoire surprise de l'ukrainien u6
sur anthony joshua en voyant ce combat
je me dis que j'ai à toutes mes chances
je ne suis pas loin du tout je suis à
confiant la question sur ce thème
peut-on lui donner raison oui ou non oui
pour vous il ya dujarrier non pour vous
grégory ne bouge en nombre oui avoue que
c'est vers vous faut réviser
c'est la reprise on fait un petit duel
entre grégory et et yan yan c'est parti
je vais simplement de 10 dit oui tout
simplement pour une résidence lui donne
raison aux on doit lui donner s'il y
croit pas lui-même personne lui donnera
sa chance c'est tout donc à partir du
moment lui il se convainc qu'il peut
qu'il peut à qui peut atteindre ce
niveau et qu'il aurait eu sa place
peut-être sur ce combat d'ailleurs vous
dites surprises moi j'avais entendu ddd
commentaires avant le match et personne
ne disait que ça allait être facile pour
pour pour joshua record et en effet
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui s'est produit
une surprise quand même aider les gens
qui les îles soeurs il était champion du
monde en titre mais voilà le match
n'était pas elle n'était pas gagné
c'était pas si simple et en effet il
avait un vrai un vrai bel adversaire à
sa hauteur et ça c'est qu'on fait ça
s'est confirmé sur le mac maintenant
voilà web quand on est quand on veut
être des sources on le dit toujours pour
atteindre la lune il faut viser les
étoiles donc si lui il il y en a révisé
ses classiques
non non je ne savais pas quelle quelle
serait la question et sincèrement voilà
pour moi s'il veut être champion du
monde il doit se mettre dans la peau
d'un champion du monde est en effet si
là il avait peur à la fin de ce match là
s'il avait peur ben arrête tout de suite
garçons et là c'est pas le cas en effet
il voit le match il dit moi je peux moi
je peux donc et je veux bon ben voilà
maintenant va falloir faire ses preuves
va falloir continuer l'apprentissage ce
qu'on disait là sur la dernière émission
mais ça va ça va prendre ça va prendre
du temps maintenant pour pouvoir l'être
il faut déjà l'être dans sa tête c'est
sûr et certain grégory qu'est ce que
vous répondez à yann ils s'en
rapprochent petit à petit oui pourquoi
pas mais il en est encore très loin ce
qui est bien le les lois et encore ce
niveau là c'est d'avoir ce combat est de
pouvoir combattre quelqu'un voilà qui a
une renommée mondiale on a parlé jojoy
si on fait le comparatif avec joe jones
qui était son adversaire en finale à rio
alors cette médaille d'or joyce a
progressé beaucoup plus rapidement chez
les pros que tony yoka joyce aujourd'hui
peut prétendre une ceinture mondiale ce
qui n'est pas encore le cas de tony yoka
si on fait aussi le comparatif sur les
deux matches son dernier match face à
millas alors c'est un très beau match à
roland garros 10000 spectateurs on
comprend clairement que joshua et elle
gagne avec erica est aussi voilà
combat dans une autre catégorie là on
était haut à la haute la tottenham
hotspurs arena 60000 spectateurs à
londres on voit que c'est encore pas les
mêmes catégories moi je pense qu'il est
encore loin et on en revient à ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure ce qu'on disait la
dernière fois il doit combattre une un
boxeur de renommée mondiale et pas des
leaders de macumba on l'a dit souvent
voilà mes duo passe temps beau et dzeko
mais millas qui n'avait pas combattu
depuis deux ans c'est pas encore d
adversaire crédible alors ils s'en
rapprochent sa conquête se poursuit mais
à mon sens il est encore très longue de
cet éventuel ceinture mondiale en tout
cas de l'espérer bamba qui vous a
convaincu est-ce que vous avez changé
d'avis en écoutant yann jarrier non non
je suis l'avis de
greg donc
de
l'excuser il ya
je suis la vie sociale parce qu'en fait
le fait que lui ai dit que il a sa
chance donc ça veut dire qu'il a envie
il veut atteindre son objectif et
physiquement je sais que physiquement
il physiquement il a le gabarit pour et
et le codex j'ai pas regardé que tout
bien extrait que j'ai vu moi je pense
que le talent est là et
il va aller le chercher il est encore
jeune selon-vous 29 ans ou
inadvertance n'est pas si je mets entre
les deux mais bon
ils
disent ils à 33 ils ont fixé à 30 ans il
en a les documents
des 30 après parce qu'il faut dire à sa
décharge aussi à tony yoka c'est qu'il
n'a pas été aidé par son sa suspension
d'un an il a perdu du temps voilà pour
manquement à des contrôles antidopage
donc c'est sûr que ça ne l'a pas aidé il
frappe de plus en plus fort mais il est
encore loin à mon sens de pouvoir
prétendre à ce titre mondial jean accès
aux enfants cf vous êtes un passionné de
golf wynn holmes j'ai regardé j'ai
regardé le combat je suis à musique je
les regardais donc alors c'est vrai je
capte i10 et il en a envie et katia la
vie atteint dans ma chaîne ce gros si
j'avais dit
non mais non mais attendez moi
honnêtement
c'est pas les mêmes combats quand même
c'est qu'un pas les mêmes combats je
viens on a vu on a vu un combat de boxe
d'un haut niveau je suis à musique mais
tant au niveau où je suis a peut être
perdu aux points à la fin était fait sur
vous ça s'est joué à 10 sauf que je sais
ça s'est joué à très peu de chose mais
c'est surtout c'est surtout la qualité
de la boxe des deux des deux combattants
cas tony hawk a dit
gg je suis travers je suis tranquille
mais moi je suis au niveau moi je sais
tout ça mais je crois pas pour moi je ne
crois pas parce que la qualité de boxe
qu'il a pratiqué face à un adversaire
qui loin d'avoir
le niveau des deux jeux sua ou musique
il s'analyse année difficilement sorti
ça rien à voir pour moi pour moi il est
encore pour moi il ya encore un cran en
dessous pour vous cibox l'un des deux
combattants à demain hyper pour moi oui
pour moi oui pour moi oui parce que il
ya le qualité et une qualité de boxe des
deux là qu'on a vu avec le palmarès com
le palmarès qui va qui est aussi je suis
un 26 combats quatre victoires 22 ko
lors de ses dix neuf ou douze défaites
du coup maintenant voilà deux défaites
mais bon 26 betty et trois victoires du
coup en trois matchs pour réussi qui
vient d'arriver dans cette catégorie il
vient juste d'arriver le luxe à dix
catégories l'ukrainienne écolo mais
quand on voit c'est surtout quand on
voit la qualité d'échangé de boxe la
qualité de 2-2-2
rendu c'est à dire on a vu un tony hawk
a quand même sur le combat qui pour moi
mais n'a pas donné beaucoup de coups
voyez ce que je veux dire alors que
quatre dans la vue les deux là j'en suis
à musique mais c'était ils se rendaient
les coûts mais il s'était apparemment ça
parle souvent dans le comité a dit
garder les deux gardes et le centre le
centre du ring moi je pense pour moi que
c'est un cran au dessus bavois pour moi
il n'est pas cité de tony l'un des
détenus lors dès lors du match de roland
garros c'était quand même aussi un
adversaire qui n'arrêtait pas de lui
tourner autour toni avait le sens du le
centre du ring et l'autre adversaire n'a
pas arrêté de courir et des deux yeux je
peux lui d'écrire ni a réussi à toucher
les deux régions touchées et des jeux
est ce que je peux reprocher cc c'est
l'intensité de son combat personnel
c'est à dire qu'elle il n'a pas mis l'un
pas donné le nombre de coups nécessaires
on veut être pour l'abattre avant à
drieu vais le battre c'est un grand mot
il ya peut être aussi un peu de un peu
de communication pour pour dire agir à
ce que c'était bien parti en titre du
jeu de la bossa s'est aussi appuyé à
combattre un fort
et les gars je suis là et j'aimerais
bien j'aimerais bien qu'on me donne ma
chance peut-être aussi parce que j'ai
c'est quand même assez compliqué il faut
le rappeler jokes d'affronter le top 10
mondial il faut organiser un combat
généralement top 10 mondial joue combat
eu deux voire trois fois par an pas plus
donc il faut qu'il y ait une part comme
vous disiez six combats de demain
j'allais vous dire mais peuvent pas
parce qu'ils ont commis il ya quinze
jours
maintenant tenir ukr doit avoir un match
encore 11 décembre le sait tous les deux
a indiqué sera à nantes et ce sera
devant onze mille personnes dont 11 au
17 décembre on va rester sur suis pas
encore un membre du top 10 ans pour ce
combat on sait pas encore la vierge de
toute façon alors tout à l'heure tu
parlais de l'anglais qu'il a rencontrés
aux jeux olympiques bêta sont le
problème qui veille à voir ce que ce
grecs ont estimé que ce serait le bon
adversaire pour toni pour entrer pour
entrer sur cette cette zone de deux
combattants du top 10 c'est que lui
aujourd'hui ils visent ils visent à
vouloir aller chercher un mec d'en haut
donc même si ce serait la revanche de
rio je suis même pas sûr que le que
longuet serait intéressé par part cela
on suivra avec attention en tout cas
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission on l'a compris a
tourné très chaud sur ce plateau comme
le fait la première thématique
aujourd'hui nous allons parler cyclisme
sur piste avec la retraite sportive de
notre françois pervis a national coup de
projecteur également sur l'entente au
sein de l'attaqué du psg entre messi
neymar et mba p ce sera notre envolée du
jour présenté par grégory mais avant de
développer ces thèmes nous allons parler
mer et de voile
[Musique]
on va donc par les voiles dans ceux ci
en parler sport louis burton participera
une nouvelle fois à la transat jacques
vabre skipper originaire de rambouillet
sera au départ de cette 15e édition avec
son bureau vallée 3 le navigateur aura
pour objectif de terminer dans le top 5
de cette course transatlantique qui
reliera le havre à la martinique ont les
couteaux micro de tv 78 on a le bateau
pour cette année on aura quand même pu
naviguer pas mal avec on a nos sponsors
et dont le bureau vallée en tête qui
nous permettent de faire un nouveau jeu
de voiles qui nous permettent de
vraiment préparé notre bateau donc on
vise un top 5 et on rêve on rêve
secrètement de monter sur le podium mois
pour sa sixième participation louis
burton partir avec son ami de longue
date des vies à bodart un skipper qui
devrait lui permettre de remplir ses
objectifs
on est déjà parti ensemble avec des vues
en 2019 c'est un ami ça c'est sûr depuis
très longtemps mais c'est aussi un grand
champion puisqu'il a il a gagné
énormément énormément de courses dans
toute sa carrière et puis c'est
quelqu'un qui a une grande compétence
dans le développement technique des
bateaux et et
et donc on est assez complémentaires sur
ces aspects là et ça se passe très bien
sur l'eau on se complète avant la course
et sur l'eau on fait tout ensemble
le départ de la transat jacques vabre
est programmée le 7 novembre prochain à
13h30 direction donc à les antilles pour
la flotte elvinois de 36 ans la question
sur ce thème louis burton at-il
l'obligation de terminer dans le top 5
de cette transat jacques vabre oui ou
non voter persiste bien sûr l'obligation
non pour vos baigorri vous êtes partagés
genre oui pour vous à bamba et oui pour
vous yann on fait un petit duel entre
grégory et bamba aller grégory commence
non avant cette publication de briller
vous avez rappelé le contexte mika il ya
ce nouveau bateau bureau vallée 3 il ya
déjà quelques résultats lauriano shawn
rae ici aussi il nous semble j'avais
noté la course et le défi azimuts où il
a terminé quatrième avec ce bateau donc
il est toujours en rodage sur ce bateau
là le vendée globe c'est encore dans
quelques années voilà on attend de lui
parce qu'ils essaient de troisième place
et qu'ils puissent briller espérait
peut-être aussi bien voire mieux sur ce
vendée globe donc là c'est un rodage si
une course en plus en duo c'est pas une
course en solitaire il a un nouveau jeu
de voiles sur son bateau il a pu le
préparer davantage donc on va pouvoir
voir aussi si bas ce bateau a progressé
qui avait terminé 12e au dernier vendée
globe qui était le bateau d'armel tripon
il me semble ainsi s agit pas de bêtises
elle était complètement refait un jeu
précise en dehors des logos tout ça il
été refait il est adapté à louis burton
avec un nouveau jeu de voiles il l'a dit
donc préparer davantage donc moi je
pense pas qu'ils aient l'obligation de
briller forcément alors il s'est fixé
l'objectif de top 5 si c'est si c'est
effectivement urgence et c'est très bien
pour lui mais moi je parle plutôt du
principe qu'il est sur un rodage encore
de son bateau avant d'espérer mieux
pourquoi pas à en vue de la prochaine
édition du vendée globe vous serez
indulgent si je comprends bien je serai
un 26e bien sûr ne sera pas déçu non
bamba c'est donc pour vous oui il
al'obligation terminer dans le top 5
pour moi oui veut aussi que d'après ce
que j'ai vu c'est il a un nouveau bateau
et donc voilà donc je pense que les
moyens sur la et il a l'obligation de
lui il est obligé pour moi gens qui vous
a convaincu que vous étiez plutôt
partagés alors je suis partagé pourquoi
parce que parole à alien après notre
sujet spécialisés et vapeur
je suis partagé pourquoi parce que il y
a tellement
c'est pas le cese exact c'est la voile
c'est plus exacte et que on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas remettre à 7 cette
discipline les mêmes les mêmes
obligations qu une discipline par
exemple sur l'athlétisme ou le 100 m une
chose comme ça là il est il est
tributaire du temps et les tributaires
des
éventuels avarie du bateau des problèmes
techniques on peut pas lui obligé faire
ne pas lui imposer d'avoir de rentrer
dans les 5e ou de rentrer et de faire un
podium parce que c'est compliqué il
n'est pas maître de tous
les éléments naturels c'est pour ça que
je me suis
jeté un petit peu il annonce lui-même
les petits sont évidemment ce top 5
comme il l'avait annoncé le top 6 dans
le vendée globe il a annoncé le top 6
dans le vendée globe il se dit troisième
donc là il annonce il annonce le top 5
donc une deuxième défaite du mans
non mais il est certain que il fait
partie avec sa dernière sortie sur le
vendée globe et sa dernière performance
il fait partie des favoris forcément
mais bon on peut pas lui imposer d'être
dans les cinq premiers ou des trois
premiers liens dujarrier alors moi je
vous le suivez avec attention le belge
lorsque je pense que louis burton est
aussi en campagne pour le prochain
vendée globe et je pense que quand en
panne c'est à dire en campagne c'est
mais laissez moi finir je vous vous y
mettez sur l'eau c'est à dire que
pour pouvoir montrer qu'au vendée globe
il sera présent il faut déjà dès à
présent faire des premiers résultats oui
le bateau est récent le nouveau jeu de
voiles c'est même la première fois que
loulou portera des voiles neuves s'il
était il à jamais une fois de 9 jusqu'à
maintenant il est temps d'aller voir
chercher un peu de sous quand même
monsieur monsieur burton met donc pour
moi je pense que ce comme on vient de le
dire je pense que s'ils annoncent un top
5 c'est qu'il est quasiment sûr de
pouvoir le réaliser bien sûr que s'il
rencontre un container perdu à un moment
bah oui mais pour qu'il révèle nombreux
ce qui fit alors sur le dernier vendée
globe n'a pas été épargné par les avoir
il dit par contre si ils arrivent à
franchir la ligne d'arrivée je pense que
s'il est au delà de la cinquième place
il y aura une déception voilà en effet
on peut se dire simplement si les boues
six et le goût de la transat jacques
vabre et bien c'est pour aller chercher
une place une place dans les cinq
premiers et moi je pense qu'ils peuvent
faire bien mieux et on peut avoir une
très belle surprise parce que faut pas
oublier que s'il ne gagne pas le vendée
globe alors ce n'était pas le même
bateau mais il avait quand même une très
très grosse casse après avoir passé le
après avoir passé l'équateur et il a
alors qu'il était en pole donc je pense
que pour moi alors bon après je suis
ultra chauvin et donc du coup bien sûr
que je suis pour d'autres et l'illinois
mais mais je pense que le foot français
sinon ça
oui mais là c'est on a même une lave aux
sorcières qui serait corps car ça mais
il faut pour pouvoir simplement montrer
aux autres que les gars le vendée globe
en 2024 c'est pour bibi et c'est pour
personne vote et je pense que dès
maintenant ça se montrer dire voilà nous
on a le nom maintenant on va bosser
pendant trois ans et ça va vous faire
drôle théorie parce qu'il faut souligner
c'est que c'est pas non plus sa
meilleure course la transat je crois
qu'il a fait au maximum 5e sur la
transat jaques alors je vais récapituler
elle a commencé en 2011 il termine 7ème
avec son frère nelson en 2013 il termine
5e en 2015 il termine 9e en 2017 et
termine 7e avec sa femme servane
escoffier en 2019 il termine 10ème avec
davy beaudart avec qui partira dans
quelques semaines donc il n'a pas
forcément brillé dans les salles est
beaucoup plus court que le vendée globe
on se rappelle du sénat du dernier
vendée globe où il avait fait une raie
manta da extraordinaire plutôt sur la
deuxième partie du vendée globe donc est
ce qu'il va être capable de briller dès
le début il avait franchi cette ligne on
se souvient avec ce millième de seconde
en avance il ya peut-être l'expérience à
son crédit va franchir cette zone du
pot-au-noir qui maintenant il a il en a
l'habitude et il a dit que voilà avec
son expérience il pourrait la franchir
un peu plus sereinement on n'est pas à
l'abri davari effectivement mais moi sur
le profil de la course à voir si sur un
profil plus courts et en duo et ce qui
va réussir à briller la course n'est pas
tout à fait pareil que d'habitude
d'habitants en général ça la course
allait du havre au brésil cette fois ci
ça va du havre à la martinique si ça
peut peut-être jouer même s'ils doivent
descendre très bas allez au niveau du
brésil pour remonter mais ouais c'est
quand même c'est quand même un trajet
qu'aujourd'hui ils maîtrisent clairement
je veux dire c'est un petit peu comme le
conducteur de tgv qui est sûre sur son
rail paris paris bordeaux là même si il
peut avoir l'habitude de faire de faire
un plus grand un plus grand parcours là
pour moi en effet c'est en fait quand
même et en plus c'est quand même un côté
hyper plaisant parce que c'est une
période fins et cd
des latitudes où les où le climat est
plutôt plutôt confortable par rapport au
vendée globe où il passe près d'un mois
et demi dans des températures
inférieures à 10° là c'est là c'est
quand même c'est quand même super
plaisant donc je pense qu'ils y vont
pour prendre du plaisir et mais voilà
c'est un parcours qui maîtrise bien ses
des mers qu'il connaît très très bien
moi je suis moi je suis je suis confiant
et je sais aussi que le bateau n'est est
très compétitif déjà dès aujourd'hui bon
bah il sera accompagné du coup de davy
beaudart il a plus l'habitude de faire
des courses en solitaire là ils seront 2
est ce que ça peut changer quelque chose
à votre avis
ça peut changer beaucoup de choses et il
sera plus motivé que vu que ça aussi
c'est son meilleur ami donc du coup ça
vous pensez que c'est une force
justement que je pense qu'aussi c'est
une force jean vous pensez aussi que ça
peut être une forte du coup de partir
avec quelqu'un qui connaît très bien oui
sauf que c'est la plus mauvaise place ce
qui les fait avec lui mais
sur les cinq dernières années vous y
opposer des aléas peut-être les allées
les arias dont je parlais tout à l'heure
mais sinon forcément il vaut mieux
partir avec quelqu'un avec qui on avait
des accointances et franchira la ligne
de départ sans être en avance et pas mal
de pénalités comme vendetta quand on est
un produit c'est une connerie gas oil
deuxième chance - suivre avec attention
en tout cas les performances de louis
burton on va continuer à parler cyclisme
il a annoncé à travers un long message
sur les réseaux sociaux lenny montrent
un françois pervis a annoncé qu'il
prenait sa retraite sportive à l'âge de
36 ans au cours de sa carrière le
pistard s'est construit un immense
palmarès avec sept titres de champion du
monde il a également raflé le bronze en
vitesse par équipes aux jeux olympiques
de rio en 2016 cet été il a remporté une
nouvelle médaille de bronze mais cette
fois ci au jeu à paralympiques de tokyo
en tant que pilote de rafale beaugier
sur le kilomètre c'est une page qui se
tourne pour le cyclisme sur piste après
le départ en décembre dernier de grégory
baugé la question peut-on avoir des
regrets sur la carrière de françois
pervis si oui ou non c'est une question
compliquée apparemment pour yann
dujarrier non pour vous non pour vous
grégory blanc ballon plus on fait un
petit duel entre jean et yann alors que
l'on pensait d'eux
je pense donner je suis fière d'avoir
aidé ou beaucoup de cartes en main oui
certains des cartes a même parce qu'il
le connaît bien mais sauf que là je
regarde simplement le palmarès du
sportif
maintenant ces titres champion du monde
qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir comme regret
de certainement deux records du monde du
sumo lit donc la langue sept médailles
au total voilà alors dit cette mère il
m'a porté tous les informations je suis
tu veux quand même parfois des sketches
au trayas deçà de sa retraite non je ne
sais pas ailleurs on ne sait pas si
c'est lui qui l'a qu'il a décidé quand
même on la réponse il a décidé tout seul
donc il faut dire que pour moi un
sportif avec un tel palmarès qu'est-ce
qui peut regretter alors on peut
toujours regretter parce que plus on
n'en veut plus fait plus on en a plus on
en veut mais quand même c'est un
palmarès éloquent donc avoir des regrets
avec un palmarès comme ça forcément
sportivement il doit en avoir mais moi
au regard de sa performance de ses
performances et de son palmarès je dis
bravo bravo champion quoi c'est tout il
ya
donc pour vous oui il ya des rues de là
et lui a un regret il weddeye d'or
olympique voilà il a été en plus
dominateurs pendant des années pendant
un an et pendant des années sur le
keirin il a remporté trois titres
d'affilée de mémoire
et
et voilà il manque sept médailles d'or
olympiques en plus sur une discipline
comme le keirin qui est juste mais
magnifique j'aurai je vois là c'est on
peut dire la seule ombre au tableau la
seule ombre au tableau après bien sûr
que c'est un palmarès
magnifique pour le sport pour le sport
français
c'était le premier à avoir gagné les
trois titres de vitesse voilà les trois
titres du sprint la même année la
vitesse le keirin et le kilomètre
il d'après il gagne deux titres les
labels et 50 en civil alors qu' il était
déjà moins en forme que l'année que
l'année précédente il légal gagne km et
kering donc cinq titres en deux ans
maintenant mais justement c'est que
juste derrière il ya eu il ya un gros
coup de moins bien et c'est quand même
dommage que que ce soit pas que ça que
ça arrive ce lors des années olympiques
et est donc on revient avec une juste
une de bronze 2 de rio
ah bon c'est la difficulté des des
cyclistes des cyclistes sur piste
français parce que on peut faire le même
bilan pour grégory baugé et
c'est malheureux parce que en effet il
c'est des mecs qui ont couru après ça
pendant pendant des années qui n'avait
même que ça en ligne de mire parce que
ce sont ceux sont des disciplines où
quand tu es champion du monde mais on
s'en fout je veux dire l'allèle ce qui
compte dans le dans le cyclisme sur
piste c'est la médaille d'or olympique
le reste ne compte pas malheureuse et de
contes contes - malheureusement et
d'agrément de sa retraite est passé
assez inaperçu par rapport à celle de
grégory baugé si on fait le comparatif
on va forcer à vous parler de la
rivalité qui a eu entre les deux mais
c'est vrai que c'est un peu dommageable
pour le sportif s'est dit cette médaille
17 médailles mondiales il a inscrit son
nom en lettres d'or au palmarès puisque
c'est le sait le pistard le plus titré
au niveau mondial avec ses 17 médailles
sa médaille olympique qui fait aussi une
médaille aux jeux paralympiques qui
finit sur une belle note avec eux
raphaël beau gilet il est parmi les
trois athlètes seulement dans l'histoire
à avoir eu une médaille aussi bien que
jeux olympiques et aux jeux
paralympiques et ce n'était pas une
carrière qui était toute tracée pour lui
il faut se rappeler aussi que il a connu
une traversée du désert à 25 ans il
l'équipe cofidis où il était arrête le
monde delà de la piste en professionnel
il ya eu cinq ans où il s'est retrouvé
sans équipe il a essayé il s'est essayé
sur la route d'ailleurs il dit dans une
interview à ouest france que c'est
peut-être son petit regret pas avoir
essayé de percer un peu plus sur la
route mais finalement en 2015 il rejoint
l'armée de terre et là il va connaître
et bien tout tout son palmarès glorieux
il y en a parlé de ses trois titres à
cali le doublé après au vélodrome de
saint quentin et non si on regarde au vu
de ce qu'il a traversé moi je pense
qu'on ne peut pas dire que c'est un
regret sa carrière oui il ya des voix là
il manque ce titre olympique peut-être
que oui ça peut piquer et effectivement
mais est-ce que lui final rien ça les
nerfs rien ne lui a été donnée à égalité
qui connaissait bien il ya du jarret est
ce que votre avis alpiq vraiment de ne
pas avoir eu son titre olympique fanon
parce qu'il marque quand même il marqua
une histoire de son sport voilà je veux
dire françois pervis pour un cycliste
pour un cycliste j'ai pas parlé de
sportifs lambda parce que en effet enfin
beaucoup beaucoup de gens connaissent
françois pervis et on entendra encore
parler j'espère dans l'est dans l'est
dans les années à venir avec avec ses
avait créé avec son projet mais mais
c'est vrai que que non il peut pas
regretter sa carrière parce qu'en plus
c'est quand même un mec a galéré pendant
des années voilà il en a chié pour
arriver là où il est là où il est allé
et c'est ces tops déception sur sur lui
tenant en revanche sur wii les
événements la prairie au l'éviction
l'équipe de france ces tensions avec la
dtn clara clara sanchez oui forcément
qu'il ya des petites déceptions sur
comment se sont déroulés les événements
sur ce qu'il a réalisé moi honnêtement
je n'ai pas de regrets mais c'est pas
triste finalement que sa retraite passe
juste par un message sur les sur les
réseaux sociaux finalement bamba peut
être pour quelqu'un de 2 qui a gagné
sept titres de champion du monde un
message sur les réseaux sociaux personne
n'en parle quasiment dans les médias par
les médias spécialisés parce que c'est
pas un peu triste quand même finalement
bien sûr que c'est triste franchement
c'est triste de faire passer ses
messages comme tu as donc c'est peut
être choquant peut-être ou pas pour vous
oui j'appelle choquant
gens
chez eux on a vu le parallèle avec
grégory baugé et il a fait il a été sur
france télévisions pour les citer pour
annoncer la fin de sa carrière
il a fait beaucoup plus discrètement
finalement françois roubaud jusqu'à
maintenant je ne sais pas si ça vienne
de lui où ça vient des médias mais on
sait pertinemment le rôle des médias
dans les disciplines on va dire qu'ils
sont pas
télévisuel mais qui sont
les sports mineurs on attend l'assaut
des disciplines on l'a déjà dit ce
plateau des sportifs qui ont qui ont des
quinze 15 titres championne du monde et
dont on n'a jamais parlé à la télévision
dans des disciplines et je pense que
j'ai pu se nommer la planche à voile ou
juste comme ça voilà donc donc forcément
les sports mineurs même avec le palmarès
qui peu éloquents qu'il peut avoir bon
mais ça passe inaperçu et puis parce que
bouger sébastien auger salut être
certainement écho et grégory à sébastien
sébastien vigiles et c'est ça je confond
les
et de mes deux pistards les deux
pistards et donc donc peut-être que lui
bah quand il est parti peut-être
sur les dix ans on peut bien la
télévision mais on va parler de tout
mais c'est simplement c'est bien sûr le
symbole de table mais c'est pas le
premier vers des personnages aussi
françois il est moins tape à dire - bing
bing mais il est un peu moins
communicatif commune i way mois - dans
la communication que ce pellet que peut
l'être grégory ou tout simplement donc
il n'avait pas non plus peut-être pas l'
envie de faire de fer et d'étaler là je
pense qu'il a peut-être tout simplement
envie de envie de envie de tourner une
page il ya peut-être une actualité mais
je pense qu'il a aussi envie de tourner
une page tout simplement et et puis
maintenant d'avancé sur sur ses projets
un mot très rapide avant de passer à la
prochaine thématique sur sa médaille de
bronze avec coeur a fait le bogie
justement vous l'avais un peu suivi un
tout petit peu un tout petit peu je
crois que même j'ai dû me réveiller
cette nuit là pour regarder pour
regarder sûr sûr sûr là sur mon
ordinateur parce que ça ne passait pas
la télé d'ailleurs mais bien sûr que
bien sûr tout de suite puisque raphaël
ben il a participé à ses premiers
championnats du monde avec moi audi dont
deux du tandem donc oui c'est jeu la vie
j'ai eu raphaël au téléphone tout à
l'heure pour pourparlers pour prendre
des nouvelles justement sur la suite de
ces projets mais met donc oui bien sûr
que j'ai suivi qu'il était très très
content pour eux parce que c'était pas
gagné la médaille de bronze alors oui il
mettait en objectif d'aller chercher
d'aller chercher l'or etc mais c'est pas
grave à savoir qu'il ya une petite déçu
aussi avant la compétition j'avais pu
leur coûter justement se font dès lors
non non non non il ya deux cas il ya
deux secondes avec la médaille d'or faux
faux faux faux pas oublier que les
anglais sont ultra dominateurs dans
cette dans cette discipline
58 secondes c'est sur le kilomètre c'est
juste c'est juste énorme déjà voilà
d'avoir fait une zéro comme comme ils
l'ont fait c'était un très très beau
chrono c'est leur meilleur chrono en
effet les conditions n'ont pas été
optimum mais il n'aurait pas non plus
gagner 2 de plus ou une seconde pour
aller chercher l'argent voilà c'est une
très belle médaille de bronze
ils ont eu une collaboration qui a été
très très courte et qui a été prolongée
grâce aux grâce au coït faut pas oublier
que si les jeux avaient eu lieu en 2020
la médaille de bronze elle n'aurait
peut-être pas été là donc donc ça c'est
c'est quand même aussi un bon coup du
sort pour pour eux et
voilà c'est en panne hier un
aboutissement mais c'est une belle
conclusion de carrière on va passer
maintenant notre page débats
[Musique]
on va passer au moment que tout le monde
attend dans cette émission l'envolée de
grégory le moment fort les yvelinois
vous attendent sur cette envolée attaque
à chaque émission de quoi allez vous
nous parler tout simplement jouer le
club où l'on peut rêver plus grands
votre équipe favorite michael celle qui
vous fait chavirer adore je veux parler
bien sûr du paris saint germain ce mardi
28 septembre le psg s'est vengé de son
élimination la saison dernière en
demi-finale de la champion's league
victoire 2 à 0 face aux citizens de
manchester city dans cette deuxième
journée au sommet de la c1 devant le
parc des princes un parc des princes qui
était bouillant bape et double passeur
décisif pour idrissa gueye qui marche
sur l'eau en ce moment et surtout pour
lionel messi un appui remise somptueux
pour la pulga qui vient inscrire son
tout premier but avec le club de la
capitale d'ailleurs messi neymar bape et
la galactique mnm était tout sourire
dans les vestiaires après ce succès
retentissant regarder ait de quoi ravir
les supporters avec ce trio qui
nous demandent où ils sont ils sont très
aiguisé d'ailleurs neymar c'est un peu
affûté 1 depuis l'été apparemment on
peut souligner oui mais voilà j'ai envie
de regarder le verre à moitié vide ou à
moitié plein la victoire est là mais
paris s'en est remis et c'est un peu
comme toujours à ses individualités
moins à son collectif donne à rauma
excellent pour sa première en ligue des
champions verra ti qui faisait son
retour primordial au milieu vous avez vu
j'ai cité les deux italiens pour
commencer forcément et aussi c'est
l'italien heureusement qu'ils sont là
ils dressent sur un petit nuage en ce
moment il est exceptionnel à le genre
sénégalais le jeune a été flamboyant ce
mardi et la complicité entre les trois
de devant ce 7ème nm ne saute pas encore
aux yeux une relation quasi invisible
entre neymar et bape et un messi pas
encore au top de sa forme finalement le
trio a été plutôt dues aux ir à l'image
de ce une deux mais si mba p1 ce qui
donc a conduit au deuxième but parisien
cela reste cependant trop maigre à mes
yeux certes la mnm n'était aligné que
pour la troisième fois depuis le début
de la saison mais s'il revenait de
blessure et nous ne sommes même pas au
mois d'octobre mais permettez-moi d'être
dubitatifs les automatismes existent
pourtant messi et neymar ont évolué
quatre ensembles au fc barcelone et ça
s'est vu contre bruges et contre l'ol où
les deux joueurs se sont cherchés quasi
constamment au détriment parfois de
quillan bape et le champion du monde
justement lui et joue depuis 2010 est
aux côtés de neymar si la relation entre
les deux assemblées encourageante un
temps elle est aujourd'hui plutôt
inquiétante et encore plus avec ce
clochard gates alors je sais pas si vous
avez suivi cette histoire un clochard
c'est le terme qui a été utilisé par bat
p à propos de neymar qui ne lui passe et
pas assez le ballon à son goût lors de
la victoire du psg contre montpellier a
lors de la 8e journée cette réaction
captées par les caméras auraient excédé
le clan sud-américains du paris
saint-germain surtout que le français
est dans une position délicate après son
départ pour le real madrid on sait qu'il
a des volontés de départ pour le real
madrid et il isolé je ne sais pas je ne
suis pas dans le vestiaire du paris
saint germain mais il est pour le moment
en tout cas sur le terrain au milieu de
ce trio magique sur le papier bas pays
occupe le rôle d'attaquant de pointe à
on sait qu'il aime et bien recevoir des
ballons prendre la profondeur alors que
ses deux compères en attaque est plutôt
garder la balle justement neymar et et
messi
dans ce climat tendu j'ajoute que messi
a paru irrité après son remplacement
face à lyon lors de la victoire du paris
saint germain à la 6e journée de ligue 1
alors peau de chez tino aura fort à
faire pour gérer tous ces égos et créer
une ensemble une entente durable au sein
de 7mn m à vouloir tout prix devenir
galactique attention psg à ne pas se
perdre en route et devenir finalement
chaotique
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
envolée de grégory genre parce que vous
êtes d'accord avec lui oui apparemment
oui
tout à fait oui je
voulais être avec le chinois
non mais de toute façon c'est toujours
les terrains problème un petit peu du
psg des stars y en a mais le plus dur
c'est cc2 de pouvoir gérer tous ces égos
quoi c'est ça c'est pas une équipe on le
dit souvent je les dis moi déjà
plusieurs fois sur le plateau mais c'est
le sport collectif donc une bonne équipe
de sport collectif c'est pas mettre les
meilleurs à chaque poste c'est pas ça
c'est avoir un collectif qui est qui et
qui qui est bien rodée et surtout avec
des joueurs qui ont envie de jouer
ensemble parce que si vous avez là il ya
eu une échauffourée entre ma paie et
neymar bon ben ça va se ressentir
forcément ça serait important pourtant
il voulait jouer ensemble oui ils ont
gagné mais elle touche des sables sauf
que ici jeune femme gâtée il saute tous
imac quelque-part talent dans le museau
voir ce que j'aime voir mais sur le coup
un peu plus plutôt que les assad ces
gens là et peut-être qui serait un petit
peu moins roulé si vous êtes si
dans le vestiaire du psg quelques
minutes même corps dix minutes je serai
suffire à vous verrez que ça vous fait
il pas réinventer ensemble et vous
régler
les moindres en préparation mettez moi
même été moins bons ratios ce sont des
enfants gâtés sur les enfants gâtés et
ils ont un ego surdimensionné donc le
plus dur une fois de plus mais on le dit
moi je le pense je le répète regardez
les entraîneurs j'ai pas les noms parce
que mon élan mais l'entraîneur qui était
pas où ils sont jamais bons opg that
d'honneur sauf que le dernier parti qui
apporte là
la ligue des champions donc si tu aurais
voilà ton most ou alors on s'en fout
c'est qu'il n'était qu'un pas mauvais
puisqu'il était à gagner la ligue des
champions avec un autre club l'année
d'après ajoute kunai emery a remporté
aussi plusieurs fois l'europe à l'égal
leur pas cher un belge et donc c'est pas
le problème à nouveau quitter le psg
pour gagner ligue des champions c'est ce
que rapportent certains actionnaires
qui tp messieurs avait été surnommée la
liste est longue finalement donc piqué
alors ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que tel qui aura pas un collectif fera
pas une âme parce qu'il n'y a pas d'âme
pour moi il n'y a pas en avant
d'applaudir match aller il n'y a pas
d'âme c'est que les enfants gâtés que
des ego surdimensionnés et sais c'est
pas la douleur qu'il faut c'est une
assistante sociale voilà donc à partir
de ce moment là lorsque vous jouez salon
aura une grande équipe pour l'instant on
n'a pas une grande équipe juste très
rapidement quant au revoir mais elio des
derniers trucs et c'est beau quand on
n'est pas capable d'écraser des mèches
ou ou des lions avec avec les g des
équipes qu'ils ont c'est
finalement c'est vrai que sur ses dix
huit ans après c'est vrai qu'on est un
tantinet peut-être provocateur le pg
vient de gagner 2 0 mais c'est vrai que
sur ses deux victoires du psg j'en ai
remis plus tôt second couteau alors je
veux manquer de respect à personne mais
se concentrent voilà c'est ça l'art
quand même mais si finalement c'était
juste c'est dur mais c'est lyon le psg
gagner ces deux matches si nadal est il
qu'on modifie les règles c'est grégory
ccc deuxièmes couteaux quoi ces
deuxièmes couteaux donc
c'est normal je sens qu'il a plein de
choses à vivre aussi j'aime beaucoup le
psg anonyme
a déjà reçu mars et
c'est pour ça que je m'invite à dire si
je suis menacé si vous avez été aussi
moi je suis de la victoire j'en ai
[Rires]
autant des stars et que c'est pas les
gérer je pense qu'on gagne on jamais
gagné ils vont jamais gagné
je pense que aussi que
est ce que vous comprenez vous par
exemple que mba père agisse comme ça
avec avec neymar ou ou pas fréquent sur
ce je comprenais sa kangoo cerner sa
après sur ce point là je
être en joueur est un joueur aussi
basket donc sur le coup de colère de
dire ça mais je pense que c'est
récession sur le terrain ou bien dans
les vestiaires présenté fut longtemps le
non non non parce que la preuve là ils
se sont régalés mais je pense qu'il faut
enfin il faut se sont régalés taurine
gagne comme ça vous avez une photo
ensemble a
donc commandé comment les supporters du
même club moi j'ai souvent tendance à
dire peu importe la manière seul le
résultat compte parce qu'à marseille on
n'a pas toujours gagné avec la manière
donc voilà ce qui compte ce qui compte
c'est de gagner moi voilà pourquoi aller
chercher des poux là où y'a pas de
cheveux
voilà c'est tout simple et ils ont gagné
contre chelsea point barre bouda précoce
et une autre moins de chasseurs ce type
on a pris les trois points et voilà
c'est fini c'est c'est réglé ils sont
leaders de leur groupe sim est là même
branlette parce que même 2 06 m le même
rooney au match retour à manchester eh
ben ils seront qualifiés et manchester
bains sera peut-être même pas en
qualifiés pour là pour la pour la phase
suivante c'est pas de se qualifier
l'un d'eux mais au final on est bien
d'accord après ça
j'ai gagné avec l'équipe qu'ils ont le
budget qu'ils ont est ce que je ne pense
qu'au résultat qu'une victoire en ligue
des champions serait finalement une
contre-performance avez vous eu d'en bas
depuis le tag qui courent à débourser
sur sur le mercato emplisseurs débourser
chaque mercato une découverte qu'au delà
des 60 millions
non mais on dirait qu'il ya également
les salaires
mais le mercato en lui-même il n'y a pas
été le salaire d'un v6 et environ 40 à
50 millions comme nous
exactement je leur parlais à mon
directeur 40 à 50 millions donc c'est à
peu près le budget de seulement je crois
la moitié des clubs de ligue 1 quasiment
rien bien sûr mais en effet c'est vrai
que quand on a cet été ils adorent enfin
rien coûte quand on a cet effectif bien
sûr que la finalité devrait être de
magna ligue des champions deux faisait
souvenez-vous le real de madrid avec les
galactiques cinq années et ils ont
jamais gagné les quais champion des
champions les listes avant cette période
de l'équipe williams et mecha ronaldo y
avait déjà il y avait déjà dit dan y
avait déjà un raul ce lancement est ce
comparatif auparavant gagné mellal pj
hogan est quoi
après on peut dire que tu es une
progression au niveau de la ligue des
champions puisque l'année dernière il
soit quand même en demi finale il ya
deux ans même si tu es une édition
particulière avec un framerate fine
gueule ait pardon pardonnez mon accent
anglais il se hisse jusqu'en finale donc
il ya quand même une progression pour le
pg faut l'avouer mais c'est vrai que ça
peut être décevante par importer cette
ligue des champions vu les sont mis sur
la table moi je vois que moi je ne vois
qu'une chose c'est que ils ne peuvent
que s'améliorer c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui il gagne en jouant mal quand
ils vont bien jouer il
mailing après je suis d'accord avec toi
je l'avais gringue à son égard a mené
vous ça suffit pas d'avoir des mecs qui
tricotent hier c'est qu'il faut il faut
les biffer 6 on savait pas où se mêlent
heures près vous
sauf que madge est certes c'était pas un
match éliminatoire ce genre en équipe ce
genre en équipe c'est pas match
éliminatoire ils jouent pas leur saison
la destruction voilà il joue pas au
trésor qui jouent pas leur saison après
ceux sur le rendu du match sur le rendu
image certes y'a 2 0 sauf que pour moi
c'est un exploit de messi qui fait un
super but est le premier but quand même
obtenu machine à la roulotte ces îles de
lifou trouille ou du bowling à rambo
vivace tout ça et là tu m'aimes au tir
afek tounes et face à réussir voilà
voilà mais ce mais après à après quand
même sur la domination sur ce bon geste
et steppas le score reflète pas le match
quoi d'accord doké eu la réussite sauf
que mais malheureusement ce depuis des
années mais dont mais depuis des années
quand même arrivé est arrivé sur le
dernier carré où l'avait là ce sont les
meilleurs et ils n'y arrivent pas
pourquoi il n'arrive pas parce qu'ils
manquent il manquait dix mannequins même
ce collectif qui pourvoit année les
enfants gâtés et ça marche qu'ils ont
fait les recrues ben 1er mai et laissons
leur disons encore ils ont encore huit
mois avant les faits mais à force à
force ils vont peut-être arriver go et
surtout les hommes les gars ça fait ça
fait ça fait deux mois ça fait ça fait
un mois et demi qui jouent ensemble et
encore mais si mes mains road mais si
nenê 6 mai cinéma aime la paix c'est
leur troisième
voilà je me réveille à qui est
volontairement provocatrice tout à fait
le débat mais c'est un début d'ailleurs
là le moment vérité ça va être à partir
de février c'est phase finale en ligue
des champions c'est que la ligue 1 a
priori au vu le commencer partie
des billets donc au niveau des fêtes de
noël
vont être moins pourquoi je pose cette
question parce que je m'attendais à un
petit peu plus même si c'est leur
troisième effectivement ensemble un peu
plus de complémentarité je le disais
mais cinéma ont joué quatre ensembles et
neymar mba paix ça fait même cinq ans
qui vous ensemble donc il y avait des
automatismes qui se créent maintenant
c'est le fond de cette former un trio
pour le moment ces quinze jours voilà
c'est de former cette triplette
maintenant moi ce qui m'a rassuré parce
que j'ai bien regardé et au tout début
après pas là dans la célébration du but
le premier qui saute dans les bras de
messi c'est neymar est gérée et de lui
le plus près oui mais après j'ai quand
même regardé un moment avant de voir si
obama était venu pour célébrer et en
effet je pense que l'ambiance ils ont dû
se dire ce qu'ils avaient à se dire
c'est resté sur le terrain oui on
effectue massoulès il ya tout de suite
compte du doigt
c'est david et mercy c'est pour toi et
bien sûr donc je pense que voilà
laissons-leur un peu de temps ça va
prendre
voilà il ya la qualité technique qui a
la qualité sur mu a
rejeté je sais pas si ça vous enflammez
autant que cette thématique on va voir
on va terminer à part du golfe la ryder
cup 2020 s'est terminé ce dimanche 26
septembre avec la victoire de la team
usa et face à l'europe à domicile dans
le wisconsin une écrasante victoire 19 à
avant la compétition
rory mcilroy lire le nord irlandais a
encensé la ryder cup 2018 organisé à
saint quentin en yvelines ont les
gouttes
la ryder cup a évolué je trouve qu'elle
est devenue plus grande chaque année
la dernière fois en france la taille de
la tribune sur le premier tir et la
grandeur de l'ensemble c'était vraiment
la plus grande jusqu'ici
la ryder cup 2018 est elle la plus
grande de l'histoire finalement quand on
écoute un commentaire comme celui de
rory mcilroy oui ou non où voter
est-ce que vous allez chauvin ou pas
partagé à partager pour n'ai pas vécu
assez
partagé aussi pour vous d'en bas
quand vous avez comme vous venez de
prendre une raclée mais voilà ben oui
vous rattachez à la belle victoire que
vous avez pu avoir deux heures avant et
attention les l'interview a été réalisée
avant la juste avant l'avant laraque et
oui forcément nous on voit après mai
mais en effet je pense que bailly prix
ils ont envie de rester sur 7 sur ce
beau beau souvenir d'eux et puis après
voilà on a peut-être aussi fait quelque
chose qui ne sera pas reproduit ou
difficilement produit ailleurs parce que
le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines permet cela
c'est voilà non mais tout le monde dit
il et disposées de manière à pouvoir
faire un vrai stade dans un dans un
terrain de golf alors que s'est pas fait
c'est pas faux c'est pas possible
partout
des gens
d'orgine oui parce que je saurai ce tous
et parce que vous jouez souvent en golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines ça
m'arrive vous voulez continuer à jouer
là bas ça m'arrive non mais si
la qualité d'une compétition
simplement la taille de la tribune sur
le premier trou c'est un petit peu léger
au real un petit peu léger non mais je
plaisante certes en et chauvet la ryder
cup
chez nous un lien course nationale a été
une grande réussite parce que tout s'est
très très bien passé et que c'était le y
avait le temps il y avait il y avait il
y avait le plateau il y avait tout ce
qu'on peut espérer pour une compétition
de cette envergure c'est certain
maintenant que ce soit la plus belle
celle un peu comme grégory je ne sais
pas parce que je vois là j'ai bien suivi
scène mais peut-être que les anciens de
chez nous dire dans le dire que les
ryder cup dans les années 60 70 c'était
peut-être plus belle peut-être que la
pige les patients sur le critère c'est
pour ça que je dis simplement il a connu
pas mal rory mcilroy un dd ryder cup
dans l'équipe européenne depuis
plusieurs années bon oui oui le comparer
un petit peu près serré que ce scénario
qui était magique cet hymne euro qui est
venu s'imposer à domicile à saint
quentin en yvelines il ya c'est plus de
60000 spectateurs qui sont venus sur sur
la ryder cup yann le disait très bien la
disposition de ce golf national qui est
fait de manière à finalement moi j'y
étais je suis pas un grand spécialiste
de golf mais j'arrivais à avoir de
n'importe quel point de vue très bien
les parties y avait la présence si tiger
woods qui est voilà qui était le petit
côté la petite cerise sur le gâteau même
si c'était pas le tiger woods qu'on
avait connu dans les années précédentes
mais tiger woods avait gagné quelques
jours avant un tournoi puis jay
haas avait à un moment idéal pour jouer
la ryder cup 2010 aujourd'hui même pour
ceux qui ne suivent pas le golf ou dit
tiger woods ça parle à tout le monde et
le fait qu'ils aient la présence de
tiger du tigre sur cet événement je
pense que ça aussi magnifié la chose et
ça ça l'a rendu exceptionnel bon bah
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
franchement je
je n'y connais pas grand chose parce que
je joue pas au golf mais d'après ce
qu'il dit qu'elle est avec jean dimanche
je suis au rugby mais
qui m'ont invité on est
dans la presse et qui dit que ça
commence à prendre de l'ampleur dont
c'était peut-être la première grosse
ryder cup de l'ère moderne peut être
aussi je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
il ya du jarrier ça fait peut être
passer la ryder cup dans une nouvelle
dimension à avant le trou numéro un il y
avait généralement 2000 3000 personnes
avec une petite tribune derrière
finalement là on se retrouve avec une
tribune 2 km 7000 personnes juste
derrière les joueurs une hauteur de 100
mètres de haut du cou pour cette tribune
est-ce que ça fait passer cette ryder
cup dans une nouvelle ère peut-être tout
simplement ce qui est sûr c'est que les
futurs prétendants à l'organisation de
la ryder cup voudront faire aussi bien
ou au moins tout du moins pareil et mais
tout le monde ne pourra pas parce que
ben les golfs ne sont pas tous prévus
pour pour cela mais
il va y avoir des peut-être des
surenchères peut-être des des
améliorations techniques mais en effet
ça va être une recherche pour pouvoir
essayer de rendre ce alors déjà ce beau
spectacle parce que bon une ryder cup on
peut la comparer à des jeux olympiques
que pour le golf est d'ailleurs le golf
aux jeux olympiques on pourra en
reparler
voilà c'est l'événement mondial du golf
qui a lieu tous les tous les deux ans et
donc voilà ouais c'est clair que ça va
amener une une recherche technique pour
pouvoir essayer de 2,2 de concurrence et
l'organisation de du golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines maintenant je
sais où la personne se se passera en
italie
en
2006 a été décalé d'un an suite à la
pandémie de patience 9 jan
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous du
thalys et du coup j'étais sourire même
s'il veut faire sur les prochaines
élections
notre but c'est aussi l'actualité de te
le permet pas si on a un ballon d'aurier
un lien
je pense qu'ils auront fort à faire ils
auront fort à faire parce qu'encore une
fois comme l'a dit jan il ya eu une
telle une telle organisation du c'est
tellement magnifique ici que il va
falloir que c'est du côté europe donc là
forcément on va tous tout le monde va
avoir avoir en ligne de mire
l'organisation de la 2018 quoi ici chez
nous donc l'italie ça devienne une
référence pour nous oui pour moi oui ah
oui les gens pour s'entendre oui oui par
quad oui parce que encore une fois tout
a été réuni et a plus sportivement il ya
le résultat il ya la victoire donc oui
peut-être qu ouvrir mes ailes qui rayent
dit aussi que c'est peut-être l'un de
ses meilleurs souvenirs parce que laura
gasnier voilà parce que l'europe est il
en mesure selon le succès sportif mais
par contre forcément pour moi ça ça
devient une référence au niveau au moins
au niveau européen au moins au niveau
européen donc italie pour moi on va
forte à faire pour l'organisation je
pense qu'ils seront surveillés vous y
serez ryder cup en italie pourquoi pas
oui
j'avais c'était ma première moi je perds
un grand spécialiste de golf c'est ma
première sur la ryder cup j'avais aimé
cette ambiance sur place je connaissais
vraiment pas l'ambiance golf en plus ça
a été dit il y avait un temps magnifique
il ya eu la victoire d'un team europe
donc pourquoi pas remettre le couvert en
italie et l'ambiance de la reine c'est
quand même quelque chose de très
particulier c'est c'est l'équivalent
enfin ses meubles équivalence et c'est
un même un poil au dessus de la
has it la coupe des nations de tennis la
coupe davis ça coupe davis sauf que
l'ambiance normalement dans un stade de
de golf est beaucoup plus feutrée dans
le tennis ya toujours les encouragements
là c'est vrai que au tennis s'est
décuplée lors d'une coupe davis
maintenant sur l'ailleurs la ryder cup
on retrouve cette ambiance de des
changes de d'encouragement qu'il n'ya
pas qu'il n'ya pas habituellement sur
sur les sur les greens situation sur les
greens et sur les tournées habituelles
mais même en termes médiatiques on est
sur des seuils d'un milliard de
téléspectateurs cumulés sur les ryder
cup on est sur des niveaux équivalents
c'est le troisième événement avec la
légion et la coupe du monde de football
donc on est sûr vraiment sur une
publicité cinq ans à hollywood super
bowl assuré qu'elle est super bowl oui
c'est ça et j'ai eu de superbes la coupe
du monde et même en dessous donc vous
voyez que c'est quand même un événement
qui rassemble dubois également que la
compétition de cricket également aux
scénarii sont haut placés avec l'inde et
le pakistan notamment pied donc il
regardait en fait on s'en fout
l'événement pouvait regarder c'est le
tour de france en
fumant si on cumule tous les quatre ans
parce que les autres y sont pas là tous
les ans alors que le tour de france il a
trouvé sur plusieurs jours si on cumule
tout c'est déjà la fin de cette émission
va terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui on termine par une
citation du footballeur à brésilien pelé
triple champion du monde celui qui pense
que la victoire ne compte pas ne gagnera
jamais rien je vous laisse méditer sur
cette phrase à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui